what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning tea thoughts
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started so
I had an eventful week let me tell you
let me tell you oh my gosh let me tell
you
I've had
I came back from the U.S okay and I had
a volleyball game now this was a big
volleyball game this was to make it to
the next round of like the England Cup
finals so I go to this volleyball game
it's a really close game we win the game
all good
but had a lot going on so I also get
back from England and find out there's
like three fires in my business I need
to put out are recruiting
guys recruiting is the hardest part of
my job it is the hardest part
but if you're in England and you want to
recruit
look it DM me DM me
we pay per guests that you bring
so
yeah dummy yummy
um oh my gosh I just remembered someone
that could recruit why did I not think
of that okay well that's different day
different day
um
so so
I have to figure out all these fires
right
also on top of that Destiny's coming in
now a lot of people want to know how
did the destiny debacle happen
if you have not seen it there was a a
debacle on the show that he was on now a
lot of people would think well Pearl you
made a lot of money off of this Pearl
you know this was good for the business
a lot of eyeballs
personally
I would have rather just avoided that
situation and left the money I'm just
sorry guys you know
but let's go to the Tate situation
not the Tate um the reason I flew
Destiny in was because Tates there's a
guy from Tate's team that reached out to
me
and he said that he would um
he wanted to host a debate between as me
moderating between
um this guy that was in the um his name
Solomon um in the UK versus someone
that's anti-tape I thought of Destiny
because I was on this panel with him
where they're trying to like have me be
the representative tape representative
of tape and I was just like guys I'm so
busy I do not know all the facts of that
case I'm sorry like I just I don't and
then they're trying to roast me on the
panel like I'm supposed to be the Tate
spokesperson because he was I liked Tate
I had a I was really thankful he came on
my channel he literally blew it up
you know um that's my most viewed video
and I don't really don't get the credit
I deserve for that video everyone's just
like oh you got 2 million because of
tape I put together the perfect panel
and nobody knows the thought process
behind panels
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
guys some insight when I put together a
panel I need people on both sides I want
it to be
two
opposite ends of the spectrum coming
together so what I did for the tape
video and a lot of people don't know
this
I put Tate on and then I put
two of the most like hated girls from
the shows that we've done on the panel
so
um originally when we were gonna go to
Dubai Brittany Renner was not supposed
to come so I was it was going to be the
two girls that were the most hated
me and Tate that was going to be the
original panel then
um
who's the fourth one
fifth one
then then
I was gonna have
um oh last minute Brittany Renner agreed
to come on that panel okay so that's
five and last the day of I was like you
know what f it I'm gonna throw Auntie
Jenny on the panel too
six
people
you can say what they want from me but
that was a genius panel okay they could
say they could say oh why do you bring
these guests
that's my most viewed video so in my
head Destiny's here big guest why don't
we bring on
to the I asked the two girls that were
on the tape panel if they wanted to come
back now a little back story the uh
Esther one of the girls on the tape
panel very disrespectful and rude but
good content right so it's like you kind
of
weigh the pros and the cons and you're
like whatever you'll just let her on
whatever okay
um so a lot of people ask like why she's
LED on okay guys look at we're trying to
put on a show we're trying to make
content here
and a lot of times you need someone on
the other side that doesn't agree with
you that you can go at it with because
it's not a good panel if everyone agrees
so Destiny's here I'm like okay let's
bring her on
auntie and Esther have beat me and
Esther also have beef right
she went on a podcast that I was sexist
racist blah blah blah but she still
comes back right
and and so
bring her so she has beef with me
whatever I don't care
um I'm a businesswoman I can put I can
put things aside Auntie Jenny Auntie
Jenny
um
she
also does not like them and so she comes
on right
I'm like all right let's bring on Auntie
Jenny and let's bring on um King riches
is Michael that is my um King riches and
Auntie Jenny those are both my talents
so they're both signed to like my
network like I run their channels I do
everything and so I'm thinking okay they
can get Clips out of this Destiny's here
let's let's make some content
um
foreign
now it's funny
I think that was everyone oh and then
there's one other girl that I was
arguing with on this other panel and she
came back to
now
it's funny because
the lady
that had the Freak Out
what's the last one I expected to freak
out I knew about the beef between Esther
and Auntie so I was like anything it'll
be Esther it'll be auntie
but this random lady actually she wasn't
even supposed to come I told her not to
come because we're overbooked I felt
like we had too many people
with like a big gap you know you want to
give them time to talk so I really don't
like more than like six when there's a
big guest there that's going to talk a
lot and this lady
comes on
and for some reason felt quote unquote
disrespected now
I'm not an expert in this like
disrespect thing
but if if she felt disrespected then the
bar is low
y'all get disrespected over everything
because basically she felt disrespected
when Michael called her bro now I
understand the older generation that's
like a generational thing that's
disrespectful to them now but there's
levels right because you can control
your reactions I could understand being
annoyed I can understand having a
conversation with him after
but
what I don't understand is getting up
threatening the whole room
over this disrespect and somehow I was
disrespectful because
she kept trying to over talk me the host
in my
Studio on my show
but it's crazy these women will twist
the story just so they can be right just
so they can be right
and the crazy thing is I was gonna let
her talk but she kept trying to over
talk me and I was like you know what if
you're gonna keep doing that
uh no we're just gonna move on to the
next topic
and it was crazy because she felt
entitled because I washed back the clip
she felt entitled she asked me if she
could talk after this next person I
never said yes
she and I was like lady you've talked
like half the time I'm gonna give the
Baton to someone else so
yeah um craziness
I have security now I officially I just
want you guys to know and the other
crazy thing
was We were supposed to have security
that night Monday we had a security
guard but he just was kind of like a
dweeb like he just was not so
we were supposed to test this company on
Monday Tuesday and then we're supposed
to test another company out Thursday
Friday because Wednesday was just like
Destiny and one other person so I didn't
really think we needed it and because we
were testing different companies and
yeah I was just like how is it the one
day this week
we don't we don't have security
so
yeah
um
madness madness Okay
then at the end of the show we thought
we made it through so she's kicked out I
am frazzled
like I couldn't even argue that show
because I am just like honestly taken
back I have never been in a situation
like that in my life okay over what
disrespect bro like I'm just sorry that
is not a big enough deal to threaten a
whole room and that's what I don't
understand like maybe it's just a
culture thing
but that's just weird to me
um
oh my God I just could not believe I was
like what on Earth and it was funny
because it wasn't even this lady kind of
agreed with me the first half of the
show we're talking about
certain topics so I was like who
out of nowhere I was just
look and
yeah so so
Michael's there dude we're all doing
their thing
end of the show Esther
she's officially banished she has
banished from the channel from the
whatever banished I
she she's also trying to overtalk me
again she's also been doing this all
show she's also talked a lot this show
and this woman
keeps trying to overtalk me so I mute
her mic she keeps going
and I'm like you know what get out she
refuses to leave so I'm like blessing
called the security from the lobby I
swear to God I would have waited I would
have waited until the show ended and
waited for security to come up just to
go get her
I would have done it on stream finally
this girl leaves a lot of you guys have
expressed concern stop inviting Esther
back you guys
yeah she's done we're done
crazy lady crazy lady
and
I also have an open invite to her
parents to come on the show I just
curious her parents reaction to this
sort of thing
open invite open invite just so you guys
know
um but yeah so
a lot of people wanted to know the back
story behind that also Auntie
um she was a lot of people wanted to
know like why auntie
left with her and she was trying to get
her out because it's just it was like an
unsafe situation it wasn't like
yeah so
foreign
yeah so this week has been Madness
um you know as much I guess money as we
make off the clips
there's nothing like your peace of mind
and oh my God
that was not even worth it oh my God
this taught me a lesson
crazy panels come at a cost and I really
wanted adversaries but
you need security and you need people
that can do it professionally and if you
can't do it professionally they cannot
be invited they cannot come here so that
was the lesson I learned
because I know maybe some people that's
their thing they want to kick people it
is not my thing I do not enjoy it I do
not want to be a part of that
so we have security Now
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel
oh my God this has been crazy have a
good time a good week I'll talk to you
guys next time bye